NICOLA MARZARI: As you have
heard that this is actually
the last class for the course,
it will be a split lecture.
I'll start for half an hour.
Then Professor Ceder
will continue and wrap up
the course, and
then at the end, I
will also spend 15 minutes
doing course evaluations.
So we'll just leave you here
with the forms and filling up.
On my side here, I
think I'll end up
discussing a topic that's
actually very dear to me.
I think it's been a very
intriguing and very fruitful
application of modeling
and, in particular,
modeling based on quantum
mechanical energy schemes
to an interesting set
of scientific problems.
We have said it
over and over again.
A set of simulations
allow you to do
sort of computational
experiments
in areas where maybe things are
happening too fast to follow
them with real
experiments, or maybe they
happen on time scales--
sorry, on length scales that
are too small to really follow.
Or as in this case,
they take place
under certain
thermodynamic conditions
that are very difficult or
even impossible to reproduce
with an experimental apparatus.
Let's look, actually,
at the first case,
and this is research
which a lot of work
has been done at University
College in London
by Dario Alfe and Mike Gillan.
So this is actually a cut
out of the Earth interior,
and in case you're not familiar
with this, the way it works
is that we are actually sitting
on a large liquid region.
So you see, on top here, we
have sort of the Earth crust.
And what is very important
for us is actually
this region, dark
yellow and light yellow,
in which we have the so-called
core of the planet that
is mainly constituted by iron.
Iron actually is a
very stable nucleus.
So instead of the early
formation of stars,
it's one of the elements
that sort of, once created,
sort of was more
stable than the other.
And what happens
in our planet is
that we have a sort of
increasing pressure going
inside, and the inner
core, so-called,
again, sort of mostly
iron is actually solid.
And we know very well
what is the pressure here
at the boundary between the
outer core and the inner core.
This part is liquid.
Pressure is increasing here.
So this part is liquid.
This part is solid.
It's mostly iron.
And for this sort of
case, we'll assume
that is 100% iron,
although there
is another problem of
really how much impurities
they are diluted.
And we know very well what
is the pressure there,
because we can sort of
look at seismic waves
and how seismic
waves get deflected
by that discontinuities.
And the pressure is
roughly 330 gigapascal,
but we actually don't know what
is the phase diagram of iron
at that pressure.
And you see, if we knew what
the phase diagram of iron
at that pressure was, we
could pinpoint exactly
the temperature here,
because these points here
are sort of points
of coexistence
at 330 gigapascal
between the liquid
and the solid phase
at that boundary.
So if you want, by
knowing the pressure,
we would be able via the
phase diagram of iron
to actually pinpoint what is the
temperature inside the Earth.
And before sort of the set of
experimental and theoretical
work that I'll show, the
estimates, actually, for this
were really sort of ranging
in a very wide spectrum
of possibilities from 3,000
Kelvin to 8,000 Kelvin.
And this is where sort of
our initial simulations
become very useful,
because really,
once you believe your energy
model, there is no reason
to sort of think
that it would fail,
either because the
pressure is too large
or because the
temperature is too high.
In all of this current
experimental capabilities
to study the high
pressure system,
the best instrument is what is
called a diamond anvil cell.
That is basically
made by 2 diamonds.
So the more perfect they
are, the better that they
squeeze whatever
you're putting inside.
And you know diamond
is transparent to a lot
of wavelengths, so they are
very useful to probe them
with spectroscopic techniques.
But basically, now,
the best you can do--
and you still sort
of break up hundreds
of diamonds in the process--
is that you can get
to 300 gigapascal
if you are doing this
at room temperature.
But as soon as you want to study
things at a higher temperature,
really 200 gigapascal is the
limit that you can reach.
Well, we want to figure
out what's happening here.
There are other techniques--
experimental techniques
to study matter under conditions
of very high pressure and very
high temperatures done with
what is called a gunshot
cannon in which you really
sort of shoot pellets
and try to establish
what's going
on in the instant in which
they hit their target.
And so they find themselves
at very high condition
of pressure, but
it's very difficult
to get accurate
data out of this.
And so we'll see
here actually sort
of how ab initio simulation
and, in particular,
thermodynamic integration has
been used to figure out what
is going on in this region--
in this region here.
And as usual, you
need to make sure
that you believe
your energy model.
So these are a couple
of validation curves.
This is for an HCP iron.
That is one of the
high pressure phases,
and the comparison between the
sort of experimental results
and simulation
where the simulation
are the sort of solid lines.
And you see it agrees
very well in describing
the equation of state, pressure
versus volume in this case.
And then in particular,
this is a calculation
of the phonon modes of
the vibrational frequency.
This is something
that actually you
could very easily do with
the quantum mechanical tools
that you have done as a
sort of post-processing
of your laboratory three,
but again, it works.
It works.
It works very well.
So once you believe
iron, now the issue
is trying to figure out what
is its phase diagram at, say,
which temperature
you have coexistence
between the solid
and the liquid.
And you have actually done
this in your laboratory
for a sort of explicit method
to find out the transition
temperature by just doing
a simulation of a liquid
and a solid phase, and figuring
out at which temperature
the boundary between
the two phases
doesn't really grow
into each other.
So the solid doesn't
keep growing,
or the liquid
doesn't keep growing.
And you see an example of
this in sort of what follows.
The caveat that in doing
this kind of simulation
is that they are still sort of
very expensive to do ab initio.
You usually need at
least 400 or 500 atoms
to do such kind of
simulation and sort
of to kill the
final size effects.
And this is, even
now, borderline
for what we can do even
for the simplest elements.
There is another approach that
I wanted to introduce first,
and this is the one in which
we actually sort of determine
explicitly the
Gibbs free energy.
So in this case, what
you want to find out
is thermodynamic stability
at a given pressure
and at a given temperature.
So the Gibbs free energy is
your correct thermodynamic
potential.
And so your goal,
if you want, is
being able to calculate
the Gibbs free energy
of your solid system as
a function of temperature
and the Gibbs free energy
of your liquid system.
And of course, the point where
these two free energy cross
is really your
coexistence point.
Above that critical
temperature, the liquid phase
is more stable.
And below that critical
temperature, the solid--
that solid phase is more stable.
And sort of one possible way
of calculating, actually,
explicitly this free
energy or, in particular,
calculating the free energy
difference with respect
to a known phase is to use
thermodynamic integration.
That is a technique that
sort of has been discussed
in some of the previous
lecture by Professor Ceder,
so I've just put
up a reminder here.
And the nomenclature is
that we are using, actually,
a Hamiltonian or an
energy model that
depends on a parameter lambda.
And the parameter lambda
is something that, say,
brings us from the solid to the
liquid, because ultimately what
we want to sort of
figure out is, what
is the difference in
Gibbs free energy,
say, between the
liquid and the solid,
or maybe between two solids,
between one reference
phase of the solid and another
reference phase of the solid?
And again, the idea behind
thermodynamic integration
is fairly simple once you
skip all the math here.
Again, one can write out
explicitly the partition,
or the partition
function is written here.
And then it just requires
a little bit of math,
sort of figuring out
that the derivative
of the, in this case,
Gibbs free energy--
well, sorry, this is
actually a constant volume.
So it would be a sort of
[? isentropic ?] simulation.
No, sorry.
It would be constant
volume, constant temperature
simulation.
So [INAUDIBLE] energy.
So the derivative
of the free energy
with respect to this
parameter lambda--
you see once you sort make the
appropriate substitution-- that
is, you put the logarithm
of the partition function,
and you work out
explicitly what is
that logarithm of the
partition function in there,
you have 1 over q times the q
over the lambda, and 1 over q
is the partition function here.
And this is the derivative
of the partition function
with respect lambda.
You basically get
an expression that
is nothing else than the average
in your ensemble normalized
by the partition function
of the u over the lambda.
So in order to calculate
what is the derivative
of the free energy
with respect to lambda,
you need to calculate what
is the thermodynamic average
in your ensemble of the
derivative of the energy
with respect to lambda.
And so this is a quantity
that you can always calculate,
and this is just an
average over your ensemble.
So let's look at
sort of how this
is done in a specific case.
So again, I just returned
here the partition function,
the logarithm--
the free energy, sorry, as
the logarithm of the partition
function.
u will be our internal
energy, and this
is what you calculate with
your quantum mechanical model.
And for simplicity,
I've actually
broken this in three
parts, and that is I've
written out what is the
energy at the equilibrium
and then the energy for
any possible configuration
of the ions can be
written as the energy
at equilibrium plus what is
called the harmonic term.
So when you expand the energy
of a system around equilibrium,
the first derivatives
are 0 by definition.
And so here you have
the quadratic terms
in the displacement
of the position
around that
equilibrium position.
And then you have all
the nonlinear term that
will call sort of anharmonic.
And it's actually, say,
in the case of a solid,
this makes a lot of
sense, because it's
sort of fairly easy to
calculate explicitly
the integral of the partition
function for this term
in the overall energy function.
And then this sort
of is reserved
for an explicit integration
than using molecular dynamics.
And because basically you have
a logarithm of an exponential,
if you sort of break
out of this thing
in the sum of different
terms, all the terms that
contribute separate free energy
pieces to your overall system.
And so we could
calculate, let's say,
for a solid system what is
the additional vibrational--
in this case, free energy--
that comes on top of the
equilibrium ground state
energy, and coming just
from the harmonic term.
And I haven't worked out
the algebra explicitly,
but it's actually fairly
easy to do these integrals
by writing the harmonic term in
terms of the interatomic force
constants.
So if you sort of figure out
with electronic structure
codes what are the normal
modes of your system--
that is, what are the
modes that give you
an expression for the
harmonic term that
is diagonal in the
displacement-- and you find out
the frequencies,
well, you can actually
substitute that expression in
here, work out the integral,
and basically what you obtain is
that your harmonic vibrational
free energy is just given by a
sum over the logarithm of all
your vibrational frequency.
So this omega here would
be your phonon frequency
if you go back to what
we had seen before
for the case of iron when we
have calculated the phonon
spectrum.
Here it is.
So here, what we have calculated
is all the possible frequency
for iron, depending
on the wave vector.
So in principle, we have
a continuum of frequency,
and we just need to basically
integrate these curves
or sum over our course
representation of them
to get the vibrational
free energy--
at least the harmonic term.
And this is it.
And so this is sort
of the first step.
This can give me, say,
what is the change
in the vibrational
free energy in going,
say, from one
phase to the other.
And I just calculate
the phonon frequency
in sort of two different phases.
What is more intriguing
is the calculation
of all the nonlinear
terms that can be very
important at high temperature.
And this is sort of the
slightly more difficult task,
because especially in a
sort of ab initio framework,
it requires very
extensive integration
of your thermodynamic ensemble.
So you would do something like
molecular dynamic simulations
or Monte Carlo
simulation to sample
as much as possible a set of
representative microstates,
but it tends to
be very expensive.
So there is actually
sort of a very useful,
if you want trick that is often
used in order to calculate
this anharmonic term, that
remember the anharmonic term is
nothing else than the overall
vibration of free energy
minus the harmonic term.
And the trick are consistently
used in introducing a reference
classical potential so that a
lot of your expensive sampling
of the phase space can be done
with classical simulations
and a very expansive ab
initio simulation are only
used to figure out what
is the sort of difference
in thermodynamical terms
between your quantum
potential and your
classical potential.
So again, sort of just
a mathematical term.
I mean, we can sort of
think at our overall energy.
So this would be the
overall, apart from this sort
of equilibrium term.
So what we are
trying to calculate
is the difference
between the whole term
minus the harmonic
term, but we actually
introduce a classical potential
that sort of hopefully
reproduces as
closely as possible
the energies, the interactions
between all our atoms.
And so we can actually break
down this term in two parts--
one that has to do
with the difference
between the harmonic crystal
and the reference system,
and one that has to do with
the difference between sort
of our overall energy term
here, or the overall free energy
term, including non-linear
fx minus their reference--
minus the reference system.
And now, this here
is a calculation
that involves only sort of
classical potential calculation
of your phonon frequency.
So this can be done
very extensively
over longer classical
simulation, and in a way,
it captures all the
complexity of the phase space.
While this, that
is very expensive,
because you need to calculate
the internal energy with sort
of the quantum
mechanical model--
is sort of you are
trying to sample
the difference between
two quantities that
are as similar as possible.
And in the ideal case in
which your classical potential
is able actually to reproduce
your quantum potential,
this goes towards 0.
So it's something that is
very simple to integrate.
So by introducing basically
a reference potential,
you are shifting a lot of
the thermodynamic integration
to the classical simulation.
And you are just using the
quantum mechanical simulations
to sort of sample
the difference.
And so this can
be done, actually,
with much shorter and
much smaller simulations.
And I want to go actually into
the details of what you need
to do for the case of iron that
is what is a good potential,
but people have figured out
that something as simple
as basically a sort
of Lennard-Jones
just like kind of potential
on top of anharmonic term
is actually good enough to
provide a reference potential.
So basically with
all this formalism,
what one is able
to do at the end
is calculate the free
energy differences in which,
if you want the fundamental
components are calculating
the phonon frequency
of your system--
in this case, specifically
for the case of a solid--
that gives you the first step
in the vibrational free energy.
And if nothing else, then
this case, a density function
or perturbational
theory calculation.
You want the phonon
spectrum, and then you
need to do a number of
molecular dynamic simulations
on very large and
sort of very extensive
for classical potential.
And then if you want,
you just correct
your classical simulations
with the difference
between the classical and
the quantum potential.
And once you have
all of data, you
are basically able to calculate
all sort of the free energies
that you need.
And I guess this is an example.
I'll show in a moment
a more telling example
in which, again, sort
of we compare actually
sort of what our prediction
are for the pressure,
volume, curve coming from
the ab initio simulation
and experimental results.
But more importantly,
if you want,
we are actually
able to figure out
when the free
energy of the solid
and the free energy
of the liquid cross.
And we can do this as
a function of pressure.
And so this is, at this
stage, our best prediction
for the phase diagram of iron
as a function of pressure.
In particular, the
black line here
is sort of the set of
simulation that I've described.
And there starts to be
a reasonable agreement
between a number of
Shockley-Gunn experiments
and a number of simulation that
puts roughly the temperature
at 330 gigapascal, just
sort of above 6,000 Kelvin.
And so this was--
when it came out, the
scientific literature,
it was sort of hailed as
taking the temperature
of the core of the Earth.
And at this stage,
it's, again, sort
of our most accurate prediction
of what is going on inside.
Just sort of to make the point
that this is not the only way,
remember that one can
also do the simulation
of the coexistence
between the solid
and the liquid exactly as you
have done in your laboratory,
in your lab number four.
This is actually a paper,
again, sort of Science 2000,
really sort of state
of the art research.
And in these
particular simulations,
they used classical potential.
So again, not very
far from what you
have done with the only caveat
that the classical potential
had been extensively
optimized to describe
solid and liquid iron.
And the way that
optimization was done,
it used what is called
a force matching
method, in which
basically you do, again,
extensive but small ab initio
molecular dynamic simulation.
And you sort of tune
your classical potential
in order to have
this more or less
the mean square
error with respect
to the ab initio simulation.
And that often, because
you have basically so
many configurations,
and so you sample
so many possible different
environments for your atoms,
it can somehow give
you a reasonably robust
classical potentials, again,
in sort of very simple cases.
This case is just
an elemental system,
and sort of in a range of
temperature and pressure.
So this was sort of
an example that I
wanted to discuss a
little bit more in detail.
I think all this sort of
research area of studying
the properties of matter
at extreme condition
has been extremely fruitful from
the point of view of ab initio
simulations.
And sort of there
are other cases
in which actually the phase
diagram of, say, methane
under high pressure
has sort of led
to a number of
interesting discoveries.
There are all the planets--
Jupiter and beyond often are
made by a mixture of methane,
water, or often, say,
in the case of Jupiter,
a large amount of hydrogen.
And the phase diagram of this
system, again, at very high
pressure is largely unknown.
One of the most interesting
sort of prediction
that was made already
in the '30s by Wigner
was that hydrogen,
under high pressure,
should really start to behave
as all the other alkali metals
in the first group.
If you think
hydrogen is in there,
and there's a sort of molecular
gas at ambient condition,
but everything below it--
it's really a simple metal--
lithium, sodium, potassium,
and so on and so forth.
And at ambient condition,
hydrogen, if you want,
would belong much
more to group seven
with the halogens
that really form
dimer and gases, like a chlorine
or bromine, than on group one.
But if you keep
compressing, compressing,
there should be a point in
which it becomes metallic.
And we haven't really
reached the state.
There are indications from
the shotgun experiments
that it could reach the metallic
state at 350, 400 gigapascal,
but this is extremely
important, because, say,
for a planet like
Jupiter, there is
a huge difference
if we are going
to have in the inside of the
planet, say, a molecular solid,
or a metallic solid,
or a metallic fluid.
If we have a hydrogen that
all of a sudden inside
is a metallic fluid,
well, we can have there
right away, like for the case
of Earth, a significant source
of magnetic field if we start
to have a sort of circulation
in that fluid.
So all of this is
very important,
and I think one of the most
intriguing prediction that
actually sort of
had originally come
just as a hypothesis
by Martin Ross in 1981
was that, in some
of this planet,
there could be an interesting
decomposition of methane.
So basically, what
could be going on
is that inside, say, Neptune,
as you increase the pressure,
your methane molecule under
the effective pressure
starts decomposing.
And this actually
has been seen in
quantum mechanical simulations.
And so what you have
is that-- on one side
is that the carbon atoms--
and you have a breaking
of the carbon-hydrogen bond.
And so you have formation
of pure carbon, of diamonds,
and you have formation
of higher hydrocarbons.
And actually, there
has always been
a sort of experimental
observation
of an anomalous presence
of high order hydrocarbons
on the surface of this planet.
And so this simulation
for the first time
provided a reason
why there should
be higher order hydrocarbons.
They are basically created
when methane collapses
under pressure, and then somehow
from deep inside the planet,
these sort of
convective currents
bring these hydrocarbons up.
But the other prediction
that, I think,
even if not confirmed at the
time is the most appealing,
is that at the same time you
have nucleation of diamond,
and so there is this beautiful
picture of basically a rain
of diamonds taking
place inside the planet
and basically converging
to the inside.
And again, this was
just a prediction,
but I think in 2002 or 2003--
maybe it's mentioned here.
No, 1999, so just two or three
years after the previous paper,
finally there were sort of
diamond anvil cell experiments
made by Raymond
Jeanloz at Berkeley.
And all of a sudden, methane
under pressure sort of
gave rise both to
higher hydrocarbons,
but also to the clear
signature of diamonds.
So they saw basically the
nucleation of pure diamonds
just under pressure, and I
guess this brought in general,
both in the geophysical and in
the planetary community, a lot
of resonance for the importance
of this ab initio simulation
in the field.
And the last example
that I wanted
to show in terms of sort
of geophysical or planetary
importance is actually
the one of water
that, as a very intriguing
phase that was sort of
suggested for the first
time, again, in 1999--
and what I'm showing here is
just a network of solid oxygen.
So here I'm just showing the
oxygen for a high pressure
phase.
In this simulation,
we were looking
at 20 gigapascal of pressure.
And what happens is
that, if you increase
the temperature
enough, actually water
becomes superprotonic--
that is a very exotic phase.
So the covalent bonds
between hydrogen and oxygen
breaks apart, and the
system is still a solid.
Again, high pressure even if
there is high temperature,
but the hydrogens start
moving around like a liquid.
So you have a
coexistence of phases
between a solid phase
of one sublattice
and the other sublattice
that has gone liquid.
There are a number
of sort of materials
that, even at ordinary
conditions, do this.
There are some salts silver
iodide that does this,
and there are interesting
fuel cell materials
that do this, because,
again, in this case,
say, when you have a
superprotonic, in this case,
phase-- that is, when you
have that the protons behave
as a liquid-- well this
system becomes a very
intriguing ionic conductor.
But again, this was a
prediction from 1999.
And actually, just
a few weeks ago
came the experimental
confirmation
from Lawrence Livermore,
and lo and behold,
the superprotonic phase
of water has been found.
It has been found that 47
gigapascal instead of 20
gigapascal as usual,
I mean, because of all
the errors involved in
density function theory,
and in this specific case,
also, the the errors involved
with the sort of quantum
mechanical description
of the vibrational
excitation that, remember,
is a Bose-Einstein gas.
And I'll conclude
with the last slide
that, again, it's not any
more geophysical or planetary,
but is, again, another very
intriguing example of what
was discovered in the
high pressure regime.
And this is, again, some
work from the late '90s that
has to do, actually, with
the behavior of alkali,
like sodium or lithium
under pressure.
These are metals that we really
sort of describe and consider--
simple metals, where
the valence electron
behave as almost nearly
free electron gas.
Think at lithium for a moment.
You have a core with two
electron in the 1s orbital,
and then you have a single
electron on the 2s orbital that
becomes very delocalized.
And now this is what was
discovered that, I think,
it was very appealing.
And at some level,
it was also confirmed
recently by the
Carnegie group that does
a lot of these high
pressure experiments,
but basically, when you start
compressing your system, what
you have is that the
2s electrons start
overlapping more and more.
If you want that
very high pressure,
even the core of your lithium
atoms start overlapping.
And what's happening
is that Pauli principle
becomes exceedingly relevant.
That is, you start to
have 2s electrons that,
by pressure, would be forced to
be almost in the same quantum
state.
They start to overlap
very significantly.
And what happens is that,
in order to escape this,
the electrons
actually self localize
in the interstitial position.
So the 2s electrons, from sort
of being around the lithium
atom, sort of moves
around and jumps
into the interstitial position.
It localizes, and it actually
pairs with another electron.
So you have that your unit
cell becomes double or sort of
becomes more complex.
And actually, your system
is a phase transition
from the metallic case of the
sort of ordinary simple metals
to an insulating case
in which, actually,
really a pair of electrons
localize in the interstitials.
And again, these are actually
sort of cutting edge research
that one nowadays can
do on a simple computer,
because studying something
like the equation of state
of a simple metal in a variety
of [INAUDIBLE] lattices
and a variety of
crystallographic incarnation
is actually very simple to do.
It's nothing different
from what you
have done for, say, silicon
or the semiconductors
in your first laboratory.
With this, I'll
conclude my part,
and Professor Ceder
will continue from here.
And again, as a
summary, just wanted
to give you an example of our
whole line of research that
has come out from modeling
and very accurate modeling,
and really going in directions
where experiments would be--
or still are exceedingly
difficult, or even impossible
to do.
And with this, I'll switch
on to the next lecture.
Let me--
GERBRAND CEDER: So let me hammer
in again the sort of overview,
the kind of guideline by
which we set up the course.
I think by now hopefully
you'll see the structure.
We covered energy methods.
We covered simulation
methods, and then
the last third of
the course was really
a kind of showing you how
these are combined together,
and that's often still
a very hard part,
how you combine all these things
to make impact on something.
And this is-- being
at MIT, impact
is the one thing we
worry a lot about.
And if you see the
kind of things that--
to integrate modeling more
with materials research,
there are really these
four poles that you need.
There's obviously
method development,
and we told you
a lot about that.
We told you what
goes into DFT, what
goes into molecular
dynamics, Monte Carlo,
there's an important
factor of dissemination,
which is getting better
and better done, I think,
in modeling.
There's now a lot of stuff
where you really just
can fairly easily
get access to codes.
You get quantum codes, good MD
codes-- sometimes for money,
but in many cases, for free.
And then there's, of
course, the education part,
which we try to address here.
This is actually a picture from
last year, or two years ago.
I actually think I have one
from longer ago where, see,
Professor Marzari still has
a beard, which is how you
know how old that picture is.
But anyway, but I think,
then, the fourth pole
is the one you shouldn't forget.
You think that for modeling
you only need modeling,
but I think what you need more
sometimes than modeling is
the basic signs of your field.
I think, without understanding
the field in which you work--
the theory, the
material science of it--
there's really
very little impact
you can do with
modeling, because you
can be a good modeler, but if
you don't know what to model,
you're never going
to have impact,
unless you choose to remain
on the pure theory and method
development side.
But I would argue that, even
then, you need to understand.
You have to have field specific
knowledge, because otherwise
you never know what is going
to be important to develop.
So I sort of hope you
don't forget that.
So this being the
end of the course,
I'll give you a few more maybe
sort of loaded perspective--
personal perspectives on
the field, and what's good,
and what are the potential
directions about it.
This is what people
want from you.
They want properties.
They want behavior.
And this is where you
essentially start,
and typically you see people
draw these kind of slides
of the multi scale perspective.
You go from atoms to
microstructure to continuum.
This is essentially--
has almost never worked.
This is great for raising money.
It's a great sort of cartoon
view grab of what you do.
It's rarely that you
actually ever do this.
There are very few
properties where you make it
across all the length scales.
And so what you really do is you
kind of connect at some level.
You sort of connect
these through your brain.
In many cases,
there are properties
we determine just by doing
stuff at the electronic level.
And we don't barter
coarse-graining that explicitly
through the length scales.
And what you're
really doing is you're
using your basic materials
theory knowledge-- for example,
that maybe when you work
on color of materials.
I mean, I had this one--
jewelers once came to me
and asked if I
could predict color
for gemstones and for thin
layer-- thin surface layers
that they could use to coat.
So in many cases, those are
fairly local properties,
especially in oxides.
So there you sort of decide
yourself, gee, there's
kind of one length
scale that's important--
this one-- and I'm going to
directly calculate my property.
So this is you.
This is, I think, why your
field specific knowledge is,
in some sense, more important
than all these multi scale
techniques.
This is my pet topic that--
it may seem obvious
that you can--
an obvious goal to try
to simulate all the way
from electrons to properties
by coarse-graining the length
scale.
But you have so much more
impact if you just substitute
that idea by knowledge.
I think, if all
the money had been
spent on trying to integrate
length scale had been spent
on actually trying to
integrate materials
modeling with material science
by connecting your field
specific knowledge, by trying
to figure out what to compute,
which is often the hard part,
we'd actually done much better.
So I'm going to give you an
example, which I really like.
It's not my work.
It's done by people
at Northwestern.
It's on intergranular
embrittlement of iron.
And this is sort of
one of these things
that you really think
you need a multi scale
sort of big kind of
modeling approach on.
Essentially, the
observation is that there's
quite a few impurities in
steel that embrittle steel,
and there's some that actually
enhance the internal cohesion.
Sort of the typical
examples are phosphorous,
which is really bad.
Phosphorus is a really bad
embrittler of high strength
steel, whereas boron tends to
enhance intergranular cohesion.
So when you sort of hear
about this for the first time,
you think, well, how am
I going to study this?
Maybe I'll set up a big
simulation with a grain
boundary in, and I'll
put phosphorus there,
or I'll put born there, and
I'll try to pull it apart.
And that'd sort of be
the brute force, maybe
multiscale approach.
You could embed that
in a continuum theory,
but there's a sort
of very simpler--
a very basic theory
that tells you there's
a much simpler way
to understand this.
And that's the Rice-Wang
theory, which essentially
states that the embrittling
tendency of a solute
depends on the
difference in segregation
energy between the segregation
energy for that element
to a grain boundary
and to a free surface.
And you can sort of
intuitively-- this is actually
mathematically justified.
It's actually a quite
elaborate theory
that you can catch
in two sentences,
but you can sort of see why this
is true from a driving force
perspective.
If you have an impurity
that has a large segregation
energy to a surface rather
than a grain boundary,
then its presence is
going to enhance surfaces,
because then it can
have that benefit
from that large
segregation energy.
So those are going to be
embrittlers, because they will
tend to promote decohesion.
Whereas the ones that have
a very large segregation
energy at the grain boundary,
rather than the free surface,
will tend to promote cohesion.
And so if you believe
Rice-Wang theory,
then this problem
is very simple.
All you have to do is
calculate segregation energies,
and that you can do.
See, now you're back
to the atomistic level.
You could set up a supercell
with a grain boundary
and really calculate
the energy there.
Do the same on the
surface, and you really
don't have to do any dynamics.
And that's what these folks did.
This is our work.
This is work that was published
in Science about 10 years ago
and already by Art Freeman's
group and Greg Olsen, who
sort of runs a company that
does atomistic modeling
and other modeling
for steel development.
And essentially, you see
that this theory works out
very well.
On one side, you have the
strong embrittlers, phosphorus
and sulfur.
And they essentially
have much higher--
this is the difference
in segregation energy
between the surface
and the grain boundary.
These very much want to
segregate to the surface.
And that's why they tend to
create internal surfaces,
whereas carbon, to
a lesser extent,
but boron to a large
extent promotes decohesion.
So you can get a fairly
easily good insight
of what are embrittlers
without having to coarse-grain
across all the length scales.
AUDIENCE: Why is the
separation different?
GERBRAND CEDER: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Why is the separation
different in both boron
and [INAUDIBLE].
GERBRAND CEDER: Yeah,
why it's different.
That's actually what that paper
is about, why it's different,
essentially.
And I don't remember
anymore, but I know
it had to do with the bonding.
This is why these
pictures are here.
There's a very-- I think it
probably has to do with the--
well, first of all,
boron is smaller.
There's definitely a size
effect, boron and carbon.
These two are much
smaller than these two,
but there's another
effect, I think,
which has to do with their--
these, I think, tend to prefer--
in some sense, have much
more bonding potency.
So in a grain boundary,
they have a lot--
they have higher coordination.
So they gain a lot more
from covalent bonding
than these two.
So these two don't
gain as much from being
coordinated by iron atoms.
I think that's what I seem
to remember, the gist of it.
But that's exactly what
that paper is about.
To sort of end, I wanted
to mention one thing
that we actually haven't
talked about that I think
that is becoming
a fairly big issue
in computational modeling.
There's sort of
two ways that I've
mentioned to go from all
this stuff you can calculate
at the atomistic and electronic
level to the macroscopic level.
One is to just sort
of think your way
through it, what's important,
and I'll just calculate that.
And then one is to sort of
do this sort of much more
explicit coarse-graining or
simply handing off information.
With diffusion, you can
just hand off information.
You can calculate
activation barriers.
You can put that in
a kinetic Monte Carlo
to get diffusivities.
And then you can hand that off
to macroscopic diffusion theory
and do simulations.
There's really a third
one that's emerging,
and that's sort of
essentially giving up
on trying to
understand the relation
between macroscopic
and microscopic,
but rather try to
determine it statistically.
And this has been done in
chemistry for a long time.
It's really only now, I think,
reaching material science.
Chemists have used
things like QSAR,
which are a quantum structure--
and I forget what the A
is-- relations or something.
But essentially, their
idea is that maybe there
are certain macroscopic
properties that
are so hard to link to the
electronic structure-- that is,
you just try to correlate them.
And I'll give you an idea--
an example.
One where this is
done extensively
is toxicity of molecules.
How do you predict
toxicity of molecules?
This is a very
difficult question.
I mean, how do chemists do it?
Well, gee, they got a lot
of experience, essentially.
All these groups probably react
with this part of your body,
but how do you even
coarse-grain towards toxicity.
It's essentially,
what is toxicity?
It's the reactivity would have
an enormous large potential
of molecules, what your
molecule can do with it.
So people have tried
to do that with QSARs.
Essentially what they say
is, for a lot of molecules
for which I know that they're
either toxic or not toxic,
I'm going to calculate
with quantum mechanics,
as much as I can, bond
lengths, electron densities,
electron negativities.
I mean, people literally
have parameterized
charged density
surfaces for molecules.
And then they do a
correlation study.
They do something like
principal component analysis
or linear regression,
and they see
which factors at
the atomic scale
correlate most to the output.
And there are powerful
data mining techniques
that do exactly this.
This is where the
field of science
really intersects with
a lot of other fields.
When you apply
for a credit card,
the first thing that people
do on the information you
provide-- that the companies
do is they data mine you,
and they predict essentially
your risk of default.
And that's all done with
correlation studies.
They have enormous
large databases
of people who have
been in default,
and they know that, well,
if you're 23 years old
you're probably more likely to
default than when you're 47.
And so all that comes
out of the data.
And people have
essentially tried
to do the same thing
with the relation
between macroscopic behavior
and electronic structure.
And in chemistry, it's very
well advanced, I would say.
You can buy QSAR software.
You do a search on Google.
You'll find it everywhere.
In sort of solid
condensed matter,
it's really sort
of in its infancy,
but you're starting to see it.
And one of the reasons I
think it's in its infancy,
it's harder--
the link between
those properties
and electronic
structure is harder.
There are intermediate scales
which can mess up the relation.
This would never be
successful probably
for mechanical
properties because we
know that things that--
two materials that
look almost identical
on the microscopic
scale can have
very different
mechanical behavior
depending on the
impurity level, depending
on the microstructure.
So you kind of already
know ahead of time
you're lost if you
try to correlate just
to atomistic properties, but
it may work for other cases.
The other thing that
makes this possible
is that essentially we get
enormous amounts of computing
power, and we can do very high
throughput data generation
at the atomistic level.
And I was going to show
you just one example.
So this is the idea that
you essentially correlate
these things, but let
me skip through that--
that you use some
kind of learning
method like neural networks,
or Bayesian statistics,
or some kind of
correlation method
to correlate output
to calculable input.
So let me show you one example.
This is something I
had gotten into myself,
and still I mean
since a few years--
sort of a very old
problem, and it
was essentially
trying to predict
crystal structure of materials.
It's a really old
premise, essentially
an unsolved problem, and
it's an intriguing one,
because you can actually
show quite dramatically
that the energetics of
quantum mechanics, the way we
do it in our density
functional theory--
is actually pretty much most
of the time accurate enough
to predict the stable
crystal structure.
So what do I mean with predict?
What it means is
that the true crystal
structure will have
the lowest energy,
but the problem is finding it.
So what I'm saying is, if
I gave you a list of 20
and I say the winner
is among here,
you're done, because you
calculate the energy of all 20.
And the lowest one
will be the real one,
but you can't make
that list of 20.
That's the problem.
It's a search problem.
It's an optimization
problem, rather than
a sort of energy problem.
So the idea we have
is that, rather
than trying to calculate
the energy of all crystal
structures, can you guess
them by calculating a few
and correlating their relation
with a whole lot of other ones?
So it's the same idea.
Let's say you have
a really big vector.
This is like the energy
of all possible crystal
structures, whatever it is.
In the end, we have to use
finite numbers, you'll see.
But can I just calculate
a few that goes fast--
that's the one in blue--
and then predict
all the ones in red
without calculating
them so that I get
to sort of a complete vector?
And the way you want to do
this is by correlation methods.
The philosophical
question is really,
if you calculate a few pieces
of energetics of materials,
do you have enough
information in there
to say a lot more
about the material?
And you can do that explicitly.
Some people would say
I'm going to calculate
a few pieces of energetics--
fit potentials to it, say.
And then with those potentials,
calculate a large amount
of other things.
That's the explicit approach.
The question you
can ask yourself,
can you do this implicitly?
And that's what we did
by building correlations.
Essentially, we build a
sort of a smart algorithm--
call it a neural net or
whatever-- that essentially
builds this relation.
So you train it on large
amounts of data sets
for which you have
the full vector.
Essentially, you're
asking yourself,
is there a correlation
between the pink data
variables and the blue ones?
And it turns out that there is.
Gee, OK.
Well, this is the
picture I forgot.
You can actually, with
a few calculations,
predict very well the
energy of other things.
And this is sort of the summary.
This is out of a very large
collection of binary metals
where we did the test,
and this is essentially
out of how many
calculations do you
need to do to get all the
ground structures in the system
with a given accuracy?
Because of course, this
is a statistical method,
so you're never going to get
100% accuracy, unless you
calculate everything.
But what you see is that with
something like 15 calculations,
you get 85% to 90%
accuracy with--
this is with the data
mining technique.
So this is an example of you
build a predictive method
without a theory, purely
based on statistics.
And you see more and
more of that done.
There are people who
built correlation methods
between very basic electronic
structure input data
and finite temperature
data-- for example,
like melting point, which
I think, as you've seen,
is a non-trivial thing
to actually calculate,
because melting point
you sort of need
the intersection of the liquid
and the bulk free energy.
So you could argue, how is that
melting point already hidden
in the energetics, and can
I extract that correlation?
So I'm going to skip
through a bunch of slides
because I want to
give you enough time
to do the evaluations.
These were actually slides on
examples of materials design.
Well, maybe I should--
a few more minutes--
say a few things about it.
One was band gap engineering.
The reason I put it in there
is because bandgap is the one
thing people always
think with DFT,
well, I can't do
anything useful.
The bandgap is always like
a factor of 2, sometimes
more off.
But you can correct for that.
People have made
empirical pseudopotentials
that correct for it.
There are actually
now methods out
there that will give you
the bandgap more accurately.
But the whole idea
is that you still
get a fairly systematic
ordering of the bandgaps,
and you look at-- can look
at bunches of semiconductors.
And what I want
to show you here--
this was actually a
Monte Carlo optimization
of the bandgap of
super lattices.
These were aluminum gallium
arsenide super lattices,
and essentially the
configuration space
over which they
searched was, how do you
arrange the aluminum
and the gallium
on the cation sublattice?
And so essentially
this was a scheme--
a Monte Carlo
scheme to sort of go
to the largest possible
bandgap in that system.
So it's a fairly well known
example of materials designed
purely by computation,
and you find
that, after about 10,000
Monte Carlo moves,
you seem to find pretty much
what the maximal bandgap is
in that system.
And then you can try to
make that will then be--
a thermoelectric is
one where there's
been several ab initio
predictions for very high
thermoelectric coefficient.
Then I'll show you one was
this lanthanum antimony,
essentially.
So my last two slides are
on the future of modeling.
I can't imagine a
better feel to be in.
And I think there's a few
reasons of-- the two things
that we essentially
benefit from tremendously--
one is computing power.
I mean, when I started in
this field in the early '90s,
I mean, I can't even
thinking back anymore
how slow and expensive
computers were.
And that's a good 10 years ago.
So we ride this curve
with an anomalous benefit.
In my department talks,
I usually show numbers.
I think, in the last
20 years, you've
had an improvement of
sort of performance
versus price of something
like 10 to 50 million.
That's how much more computing
power you get for your buck
now than actually
about 15, 20 years ago.
That's enormous.
There are no other techniques
in material science
that do that, period.
So you ride this enormous curve.
And for whatever
people say, this
is likely to continue at
least for quite a while.
I think another one is that
we benefit tremendously
from all the developments
in condensed matter theory,
because this allows
us to compute.
Those allow us-- the
benefits in condensed matter
theory allow us to compute
things much more accurately.
And the third leg is the basic
materials theory development,
which is probably
the sort of weaker
leg of the three-legged stool.
But so this is
one of the reasons
this field is still very good.
You should keep into
account scaling,
which we've only sort of
cursorily said something about.
But here's some examples of
why scaling can kill you.
I put out some
hypothetical examples
of linear scaling examples, cube
scaling examples, and worse.
If you take an example
of linear scaling,
I think molecular dynamics
with real space potentials
is probably pretty well
up to linear scaling
these days, because you
can partition space.
As soon as you start
partitioning space
with finite range
potential, you can
get basically linear scaling.
So I figured out, what
can you do in 40 years,
assuming we get about a
factor of 10 to the sixth.
That's what you would
get from Morse's law.
40 years is about
when you retire.
So I mean, I'm
long gone by then,
but you guys are
going to retire.
So where will you be?
Well, let's say we can
do 10 to the 8 atoms.
So what is that, 100 million?
The record stands
more at a billion now,
but nobody kind of performs
at the record all the time.
You have to essentially
take what you can
do on an almost daily basis.
So if you do 100 million
atoms with potentials,
you'll be able to do
10 to the 14 atoms.
What does that buy you?
I'm not totally sure.
You have to ask yourself, what
can you do with 10 to 14 atoms
that you can't do
with 10 to the 8?
Because a lot of things don't
depend on the number of atoms.
They depend on the length scale.
And so of course,
the length scale
is the cube root of
the number of atoms.
So there, you've
only gained about--
well, you've gained about a
factor of 100 in length scale.
But if you go to something
that scales like the cube.
And I know this is a
little overdoing it--
LDA scales in large problems is
much more like n squared log n.
But let's say on smaller
problems it's just
like the cube of n.
So if you can do 1,000
atoms now, when you retire,
you'll be able to
do 100,000 atoms.
So where is that
going to take us?
I think it's going to allow
us to do some things that we
have a hard time with--
biological species, for example,
where even this is really
cutting it close.
You want to do proteins and DNA.
Yeah, people do dabble in
it now, and you can do it,
but it's fighting
against the frontier.
You've got to do solvent,
and so people now
make more ad hoc models
for including the solvent.
I think, when you
do 100,000, you
are going to do
biology much more.
Are you going to do
mechanical behavior?
I don't think so.
Not in the direct
ab initio scale.
This is probably by no
means enough to sort of span
the length scale from
atoms to microstructure.
Of course, if you believe that
we're all going to be doing
[? LDA ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
now you're up to--
what is this, a billion atoms?
So starting to count.
Of course, when you
have a billion atoms,
you're going to have to
figure out how to look at them
and how to extract data from
them, which is non-trivial
at these large simulations.
The people who sort of
broke these frontiers--
there was a group at Louisiana
State that, for the longest
time, drove this forward.
And I think they may have
done the first billion atom
simulation.
A lot of the research is in
data transfer, data analysis,
visualization, because
think about it.
When you have a
billion atoms, how
do you decide what's going on?
You just look at it, or like--
so that's actually a big
chunk of that research.
And then I took one
that's kind of excessive,
but let's say you do [INAUDIBLE]
configuration interactions,
which is as close
to-- essentially as
close to the exact
solution maybe
that you could get
for quantum mechanics,
except maybe quantum
Monte Carlo now.
But that scaling
is depending on who
you believe is somewhere
from n to the fifth
to n to the seventh.
It's such small
numbers that it's not
even really sure you can
quite calibrate the scaling.
But so if you can
do 10 atoms now,
you can only do 100 by
the time you retire.
So these things are
useful for calibration,
but they're not going to allow
us to, say, do DNA and do it
more accurately.
So the only reason I'm saying
is that you will still not
be able to rely on Morse's
law for all your problems.
You still have to
figure out ways
to, in a sort of smart
way, use computations.
I always find it funny
the proposals I read of we
can't quite compute this,
but next year we can.
Well, most stuff
you can't compute
today you won't be able to
compute next year either.
And so you'll still
have to find shortcuts.
If you count on being able to
sort of put materials in a box,
and simulate the hell out
of them, and sort of figure
out what comes up, I
think it's unlikely
that that will happen
in any reasonable time
for a lot of properties.
There are properties
you can do it for.
But for most things,
I don't think you can.
So it was a pleasure
teaching you.
Professor Marzari and
I had a lot of fun.
We always have a lot of
fun with this course.
We're going to leave you with
the course evaluations, which
have to be done.
And can I count on you?
We're not allowed to
touch these, so one of you
has to return this to
department headquarters,
or to Kathy Farrel.
Can I count on one of you just
to pick them up and like--
OK, thanks, everyone.
OK, thank you.